yesterday what we covered was two things
number one
very simple kinds of tree equations like
as simple as it gets
and how you approach your team does we
also looked at the problem with t
results
which um people googled without much
success
which was now yeah okay yeah yeah
thumbs up okay textbook namely that when
you use two results
team results don't work for particular
values
of partic particular solutions namely if
x equals pi
is a valid solution to your equation t
results won't pick them up
they just won't appear okay so therefore
you have to test this result
every time you use t results so we're
like ah that's not so great
but that's the disadvantage there's
always a disadvantage that you have when
you're trying to get this common
denominator business
and make it simple for you so today i'm
just going to look at a harder example
i'm going to take it from the first
exercise in this booklet one of the
questions that i haven't assigned
but to be honest it's just like the ones
that have been assigned okay
so have a have a look at exercise 24.5
question
six we're right down the bottom uh i
think in this exercise i asked you to do
every second letter
starting from a right so let's do b
okay
now when you look at this question you
remember so far we've been looking at
like identities and equations
and we've been solving it the old way
that we used to be able to solve things
and then i was like okay well look how
this is how you do it with t results and
a lot of the same well
you know if i can do it the old way
why do i have to do it this new way and
the answer is well there are some kinds
of questions
where the old way either just flat out
doesn't work
or it leads to even more problems and
like a longer method
than the new one so here's a classic
example
you're more used to dealing with these
questions you did these at the end of
your tent hopefully
if for instance there was a squared up
there now you're like
oh wouldn't adding a square wouldn't
that make it worse rather than better
and the answer is no what what does that
squared
help you with okay two things
number one um you can convert this into
a
one minus cos squared right actually
five minus five cos squared okay and
then what you've got
is a quadratic you can just deal with it
like you normally do okay
but not having that sign there
okay it's a bit problematic okay you
could sort of try and do the same thing
you could say well if you sort of
rearrange the pythagorean
identity you get this but that's got
problems too because
if you remember this is actually not
quite true it's actually plus or minus
and that's
it's not a good word to go down you have
to do cases and it's gross okay
so this is a perfect example of where t
results
and later on auxiliary angle and we
learn it is really the best way to go
okay so let's see if we can review from
yesterday what's the first step if
you're going to do t
results with a question like this
let t good so we're going to talk about
ts
and stuff so bring it in question what
question are we doing this is i think
it's six
b six b okay so let t equal
again okay now remember like i said
it doesn't always equal tan excellent
for instance if this was 5
sine 2x and 12 cos 2x you would let this
be
just a regular 10x okay but since this
is just
1x this becomes the half angle all right
yeah
you're always going to test um you're
always going to test pi
based on whatever value you get in here
right so
if i put pi in there it breaks right so
yes if i just had tan x right
the value that makes that break is pi on
two like you said
and if i had changed it to be you know
tan 2x then the value that would make
that break is
pi on four so you're always looking for
where does the asymptote come from in
tan
good pick up now what was that once
you've introduced
now um recite your results for
the bits that you need okay so i need
sine i need cosine okay
so therefore sine x
and cos x
okay now um this step in here right
do you have to do it eventually you'll
get so good at tear results that you'll
not have to draw the triangles
i hope um you'll remember these you've
got do i have to write down
every time i do it just for this reason
so then when i substitute back in i know
i'm putting the right things in the
right spots
these can often get very confusing with
each other you don't want to mix them up
because what will happen is
you'll get some wrong equation and then
you'll do all this work and it'll all
be wrong okay if you do it correctly
you'll get it carried forward
but just as likely because the numbers
end up being gross okay
um you'll make some kind of arithmetic
error so you'll make two errors you made
the wrong substitution and then some
subsequent one
so that's why i write this down even
though i'm doing this videos
okay let's make the substitution this is
going to be 5
times this
plus 12 times this
equals 2. okay so now that i've made my
substitution i can just set about the
work of solving this
okay now because i've got one plus t
squared on the denominator of both of
these
makes more sense just to multiply
through by one plus t squared
so what's this going to become 10 t plus
12
minus 12 t squared equals 2
do that plus 2 t squared see what i've
done
just multiplied through all the way
all right now this is the quadratic that
i wanted so let's just simplify
out uh if i subtract 2 plus 2 squared
squared from both sides
i'm going to get 10 t plus 10
minus 14 t squared okay
so just to simplify a little bit before
i jump into the quadratic formula
divide everything through by minus two
and that's where i'm sitting okay and
you can look at that and stare at it for
a little while
it's not going to factorize nicely and
it excuse me it often doesn't
and that's fine okay what i'm going to
do is jump into
the quadratic formula for this so i'm
going to have t equals
okay minus b plus or minus
b squared minus
4 a c
yep all over 2a
so just do a bit of number crunching
that's going to be
140 so this would be 165.
and there's not all that much you can do
with that i mean
yeah and it doesn't matter now i know it
looks terrible okay
but remember this is tan of x
on two okay so these numbers over here
you want to get your calculator out
these are going to be equal to let's
have a look here now
five minus this one
and five plus this one
do them one at a time don't get them too
mixed up with each other
uh let's do the first one 5 minus root
165
and divide by 14.
okay you get a value for tan
of x on two so to get the angle out of
it just
take tan inverse okay